[Musique]
fiscal c'est un truc inimaginable
d'avoir un ski hiller haïtien ou même de
représenter haïti tandis jeux olympiques
d'hiver
le jour d'haïti on a pas de neige qu'est
ce qu'on a on a le coeur on à la fois on
est un pays fier à ces petits mots en ou
détruits on nous fait des trucs bon se
relève et on grimpe les montagnes c'est
pour ça qu'on ira aux jo à pékin
je me sens aimé ouais je suis très ému
je préside
ce régime parce que c'est tout le
travail
je sens que ça va aboutir
je dis qu'est ce que je pouvais faire en
2010 après le tremblement de terre pour
vraiment con con et d'haïti et après je
me suis dit
le ski et je me suis dit pourquoi pas
représenté haïti aux championnats du
monde ce qui s'est passé ici que
j'appuie la combinaison j'ai eu le
blouson c'est haïti en fait les gens
m'appelaient dans la rue haïti du coup
et moi appelé barras la fillette
pourquoi parce qu'il ya rasta rockett
donc ça veut dire coule pas dans la luge
mois et des pics et ses couilles dans
les piquets du coup rasta piquet
tout le monde rigolait mais moi je leur
dis mais je suis pas bon skieur venez me
rejoindre donc j'ai cherché partout des
jeunes au canada
en europe ou d'un panier chez nous faut
ce soit forcément la diaspora des
enfants la diaspora qui viennent dans
les petites blagues et y est de
représenter haïti
signer haïti à port-au-prince j'ai été
adopté à l'âge de trois ans par des
parents montagnards italien qui vivent
en france
haïti a toujours été la terre d'où il
venait il y avait une maman sa maman est
morte pendant qu' il y avait la
transition de l'adoption et haïti n'a
jamais été un tabou pour nous le fid
d'avoir renoué avec haïti de ski avec
haïti j'ai l'impression de de redevenir
un vrai ici à 100%
c'est la première fois qu haïti sera aux
jeux olympiques d'hiver c'est juste
impensable si on m'avait dit quand
j'étais petit qu'un jour on pouvait
représenter haïti aux jeux olympiques je
n'y aurais pas cru
et c'est vrai gritti c'est une
catastrophe on a des tremblements de
terre on a des trucs et toupet et je
voudrais que les gens comprennent que si
on donne une image positive du pays on
arrivera à s'en sortir les gens c'est la
force l'union fait la force mais ça
c'est si c'est notre devise
intersport à vous êtes tous là on a
besoin de vous le pays a besoin de se
reconstruire tous les sportifs d'accord
qu'ils veulent représenter haïti c'est
possible
la diaspora il faut le supporter on a
besoin de jeunes voulaient canadien j'ai
besoin de vous venez venez
d'un petit secret secret c'est que c'est
que j'ai porté haïti pendant dix ans
j'ai porté ce ski est
cette équipe cette valeur est en fait le
truc tout au plus beau du monde
[Musique]
souhaite que je jette pas faux j'étais à
présenter si je serai le porte drapeau
voilà et ça c'est un truc pour tous les
athlètes qui viendront derrière juste à
côté de moi derrière moi c'est une
grande fierté et pour toutes les autres
années après voilà mais c'est un secret
[Musique]